I want to talk to you first about your
new song and the response has been
getting it seems like the words are more
important now than ever especially with
everything that's happened not just in
orlando but also needs to yeah i mean
everywhere right now there seems to be a
lot of senseless acts of violence going
on and it's funny when we did it we did
it for orlando we wrote the word
specifically for that lin-manuel and
myself and and it's just taking on a
even more meaning since then
it's one of my favorite songs I've ever
done and it's just something different
about it than any other song I've ever
done but yeah I just feel like the world
hates that message right now of the fact
that love is the answer in love is the
key and that's what really makes the
world a beautiful place and makes it
makes it go around et was with Jennifer
Lopez on Saturday in la at the premiere
of her new movie Ice Age collision
course this film deals with the
emptiness looming now I know that's a
long way away but is that something
you've thought about you dreading are
you excited about it from the minute
they're born they're like oh they're
gonna leave one day yeah it's funny it's
just I love the Ice Age franchise it's
all about family it's the people in your
life that you're born with but also
people that you acquire a long way and
how important that is and so I love
being part of it
you